[Music]
lay down for yourself at the outset a
certain stamp and type of character for
yourself which you are to maintain
whether you are by yourself or are
meeting with people
and be silent for the most part or else
make only the most necessary remarks and
express these in few words
but rarely and when occasion requires
you to talk talk indeed but about no
ordinary topics do not talk about
gladiators or horse races or athletes or
things to eat or drink
topics that arise on all occasions but
above all do not talk about people
either blaming or praising or comparing
them
if then you can by your own conversation
bring over that of your companions to
what is seemly
but if you happen to be left alone in
the presence of aliens keep silence
do not laugh much nor at many things nor
boisterously
refuse if you can to take an oath at all
but if that is impossible refuse as far
as circumstances allow
avoid entertainments given by outsiders
and by persons ignorant of philosophy
but if an appropriate occasion arises
for you to attend
be on the alert to avoid lapsing into
the behavior of such layman for you may
rest assured that if a man's companion
be dirty the person who keeps close
company with him must have necessity get
a share of his dirt even though he
himself happens to be clean
in things that pertain to the body take
only as much as your bare need requires
i mean such things as food drink
clothing shelter and household slaves
but cut down everything which is for
outward show or luxury
your sex life preserve purity as far as
you can before marriage
and if you indulge take only those
privileges which are lawful
however do not make yourself offensive
or centurious to those who do not
indulge
and do not make frequent mention of the
fact that you do not yourself indulge
if someone brings you word that so and
so is speaking ill of you do not defend
yourself against what has been said but
answer yes indeed for he did not know
the rest of the faults that attached to
me if he had these would not have been
the only ones he mentioned
it is not necessary for the most part to
go to the public shows if however a
suitable occasion ever arises show that
your principal concern is for none other
than yourself which means wish only for
that to happen which does happen and for
him only to win who does win
for so you will suffer no hindrance but
refrain utterly from shouting or
laughter at anyone or great excitement
and after you have left do not talk a
great deal about what took place except
insofar as it contributes to your own
improvement
for such behavior indicates that the
spectacle has aroused your admiration
do not go rashly or readily to people's
public readings but when you do go
maintain your own dignity and gravity
and at the same time be careful not to
make yourself disagreeable
when you're about to meet somebody in
particular when it is one of those men
who are held in very high esteem propose
to yourself the question what would
socrates or zeno have done under these
circumstances and then you will not be
at a loss to make proper use of the
occasion
when you go to see one of those men who
have great power propose to yourself the
thought that you will not find him at
home that you will be shut out that the
door will be slammed in your face that
he will pay no attention to you
and if despite all this it is your duty
to go go and take what comes and never
say to yourself it was not worth all the
trouble
for this is characteristic of the layman
that is a man who is vexed at externals
in your conversation avoid making
mention at great length and excessively
of your own deeds or dangers because it
is not as pleasant for others to hear
about your adventures as it is for you
to call to mind your own dangers
avoid also raising a laugh for this is a
kind of behavior that slips easily into
vulgarity and at the same time is
calculated to lessen the respect which
your neighbors have of you it is
dangerous also to lapse into fall
language when therefore anything of this
sort occurs if the occasion be suitable
go even so far as to reprove the person
who made such a lapse if however the
occasion does not arise at all events
show by keeping silence and blushing and
frowning that you are displeased by what
has been said
chapter 33 of epictetus and coridian is
an entire set of precepts with a few
reasonings thrown in
about how one ought to live the stoic
life and they're they're mostly having
to do with conduct
all sorts of different topics that are
that are all bundled together
in this chapter so i'm just going to go
through each of them and turn it and
comment on them a little bit uh though
the key thing is that he says at the
beginning that we should lay down for
ourself at the beginning a certain stamp
and type of character for yourself
which you are to maintain whether you
are by yourself or
meeting with people now
he talks about um
we could say
an arrangement a toxon um a a
it could be stamp it could also be the
way in which we arrange ourselves and
then two bone that that's that's also a
stamp but we get the word type from that
decide for yourself
what kind of person you're going to be
and then he says maintain that you're
going to maintain this not only
when you're engaging with other people
but here's the real test whether you
also do that when you're by yourself try
to be one person you might say
both in dealing with others and in
dealing with yourself
so now he goes into the specific advice
the first thing that he says is be
silent for the most part or else make
only the most necessary remarks and
express these in a few words why is it
so important to hold your piece so to
speak well this is good advice in part
because
when we when we engage in a lot of idle
chatter
you know we're easily getting entangled
with other people's affairs we're
chitter chattering about all sorts of
things that don't usually concern us
and we can you know easily cause other
people pain
get them riled up cause all sorts of of
issues to arise
so
you know make necessary remarks express
these in a few words the stoics were
renowned for speaking in what was called
the laconic fashion comes from laconia
where the spartans were they tried to
express things in as few words as
possible and why so that they didn't
make a big deal of themselves and this
isn't a culture that really valued not
only rhetoric but sort of an overflowing
a copia in latin of or an abundance of
of words
so he says rarely and when occasion
requires you to talk talk indeed but
about no ordinary topics don't get drawn
in to the the ordinary uh topics of the
day the things that everybody else is
talking about so for example uh what
you're seeing in your facebook stream
maybe don't talk so much about that as a
matter of fact if we're considering our
facebook postings to be a kind of
talking
maybe don't post so much right
you don't need to put your thoughts out
there for everybody else to scrutinize
to react to to say oh what a what a
brilliant person or what what a terrible
person any of those sorts of things now
he has examples that are a little bit
harder for us to relate to in the
present but we can think about what
would be contemporary examples like this
don't talk about gladiators or horse
races or athletes okay so don't talk a
lot about sports
why not well
sports are
for many people a way in which we can
find some common ground
and
uh just you know engage at a very
superficial level right and the goal for
the stoic is not to live a superficial
life
um things to to eat or drink
uh you know he says topics that arise on
all occasions so you know in in a
culture that has become obsessed with
what we now call food porn perhaps
talking about the latest restaurant or
talking about how you prepared these
pears for this meal
you know or this wine sauce maybe that's
not quite so important
he gives a few other things he says but
above all do not talk about people
don't engage in what we call gossip
or
evaluation or
speculation whatever you want to call it
right we've got different names for it
it's really the same thing how does he
define it he talks about praising and
blaming
this is uh something that the ancients
gave a lot of thought to
we don't need to praise people
excessively and we don't need to be
always criticizing people and then he
says something really interesting it's
translated here as comparing them but
really the greek term uh conveys the
sense of of engaging
in judgment about them and connecting
the judgment
with um somebody else
so
you know
that's that's probably a good thing to
keep in mind the term is actually uh sun
cree known
is to make a judgment about something to
be to be a judge right
name to judge together or to judge
across the board
it's not just when we compare people to
each other
that we're making you know objective
comparison we're really engaging in in
judgments about their value
about what matters what doesn't matter
about who's up who's down and it can get
very easy to get caught up in in that
sort of activity
so he says if then you can by your own
conversation bring over that of your
companions to what is seemly try to you
know bring them around
but if you happen to be left alone in
the presence of aliens just keep silence
if you've got you know a bunch of people
like say you're riding the bus you know
and people are chattering about all
sorts of things you don't have to make
conversation
and you're not being rude by sitting
down next to somebody in an airplane for
example and and you know after you say
hello uh reading your book you're not
hurting them
they may want to make chit chat with you
about all sorts of things but there's no
no requirement that you do that
he goes on
and he talks about laughter he says do
not laugh much nor at many things nor
boisterously and that's that's a very
quick uh you know comment right there a
little bit later on he's going to talk
about
laughing as well he says avoid raising a
laugh or this is a kind of behavior
what's wrong with it it easily slips
into
vulgarity into a kind of common life
and at the same time is calculated to
lessen the respect which your neighbors
have of you if you're if you're joking
around a lot it may be difficult for
other people to take you seriously and
you can say well what do you care you're
a stoic you don't care what other people
think well it does matter sometimes for
your ability to fulfill your role
or
you know you don't want to give scandal
to other people as as well
he goes on and he says refuse if you can
to take an oath at all but if that is
impossible refuse as far as
circumstances allow why is this
important is this you know we should
there's something wrong with taking
oaths there's something wrong with um
taking oaths excessively you know
swearing all sorts of things the person
who has to do that a lot usually it's
because there's there's something going
on either they lack confidence in
themselves or other people ought to lack
confidence in them
and so you know we should we should try
to avoid that sort of behavior
the next thing that he has to say is
that we should avoid entertainments
given by outsiders and persons ignorant
of philosophy now does that mean that we
should avoid any sort of social life
with people who don't have at least a
bachelor's degree in philosophy that is
totally not what he's saying instead
he's saying something quite different
those people who are whose lives are not
informed by sort of you know a
seriousness that philosophy would give
them and this doesn't have to
necessarily come through academic
philosophy it's possible for some
fisherman who is illiterate and just
happens to have integrity to be a
philosophical person but he says avoid
entertainments given by people who don't
understand that but if an appropriate
occasion arises for you to attend if
it's if it's seemly
be on the alert to avoid lapsing into
the behavior of such laypeople people
who don't understand how to behave
four you may rest assured that if a
man's companion be dirty the person who
keeps close company with him must have
necessity get a share of his dirt even
if he happens to be clean so you know it
it's
it's this is a common temptation
especially for those who are making some
progress to think well i'm going to go
out there and i'm going to be like a
shining beacon
and i'll you know i'll bring everybody
up to my level no you've got to watch
out that they're not going to bring you
back down to their level where they're
not actually happy but you know are at
least trying to be happy
you you know if you're going to be
serious about stoic philosophy you want
to
keep keep it up all the time
he says in things that pertain to the
body there's a certain kind of
asceticism that goes with stoicism take
only as much as your bear need requires
take only as much as you actually
do need and if we think about how much
we really do need it's it's usually not
quite so much as our wants or our
desires uh tell us we need right there's
a lot of things we don't actually need
you know watching netflix probably not a
need you may feel bad if you turn it off
but you'll get over it right
um eating meat for example a lot of
discussions about that
most people don't need to eat that much
meat perhaps we can get by without
eating any
we certainly don't need to be eating
meat at every single meal and if
somebody takes that away from you
they're not going to kill you
so you know
he talks about all these things
food drink
clothing
shelter literally your house and now
notice what else he says and household
slaves the greek for that is waiketian
what does he mean by that we don't have
household slaves today what we do have
is technology how much technology do we
need
how how much stuff do we need to have we
could also ask for myself how many books
do you need to have this is a
conversation that academics continually
need to have with themselves can i
get rid of some of these books maybe if
i need them i can go to the library or
do i need to lug around thousands of
volumes with me everywhere that i go
it's a good question
so he says
try to reduce yourself to the these
needs cut down on everything which is
for outward show
which is for other people
or for
luxury which is for
you know
feeling good
indulging yourself that's not to say
that you know you can't do it every once
in a while just realize that the more
that you engage yourself in luxury the
more setbacks you're producing for
yourself along the stoic
path
he talks also about about sexuality and
about how we ought to engage in sexual
activities he says something really
interesting here at the end as well
at first he says in your sex life
preserve purity as far as you can
the sex life is aphrodisiac so we might
translate that not just as in your
sexual life but also in your romantic
life in everything that percei
that that has to do with um sexual
desire right so in your sex life
preserve purity as far as you can before
marriage and if you indulge he says take
only those privileges which are lawful
so you know don't do anything that
actually goes against the
the laws of where you're living now of
course for some people that may be very
restrictive
uh some people that may be anything goes
depending on on where you're living but
there's you know there's some sort of
rationality that we can we can stick to
there uh you know you ask yourself is
this going to be helping me on my way or
is this going to turn into a kind of
entanglement now notice what else he
says
do not make yourself offensive
or centurious that is don't look down
upon
other people don't don't literally here
don't refute them
don't don't start being a pain in the
butt for other people who do indulge
also he says don't make frequent mention
of the fact that you yourself don't
indulge in that so if you don't like the
fact that
certain people are are promiscuous
because you're not promiscuous you don't
have to say anything about that and you
don't have to make a big deal the fact
that you're being faithful just show
yourself as being faithful that's enough
as a matter of fact you don't even need
to worry about what they're doing over
there unless it directly affects you
same thing with what other people are
doing with their sexual behavior you
know who they're they're sleeping with
what sort of practices they're involved
in
you don't need to be focused on that
it's enough that you maintain
your integrity that's what epictetus is
saying
we might think about that in terms of
many other things as well
now here's another point that he brings
up that's very interesting he says if
someone brings you word that
so and so is speaking ill of you
don't defend yourself against what has
been said
instead of trying to defend yourself
or contest it or prove that they're
wrong
answer something that's probably
truthful
say yes indeed for he did not know the
rest of the faults that attached to me
if he had these would not have been the
only ones that he mentioned somebody
says yeah you're a blabbermouth you can
say yeah well i guess i am
but that's not the the least of my
faults and it's nice of you to only
concentrate on the surface level stuff
you know you don't have to mention what
else is going on with you you have to
say yes i i also am terrible in managing
my money or i keep you know making
commitments to learn foreign languages
and then never actually get around to
learning them or i treat my friends
badly or i give into anger over here you
don't have to bring up all that stuff
but you can say to the other person and
this kind of disarms them yeah i guess
if you if you really knew me that would
be the least of the things that you have
to complain about
and like i said it's probably truthful i
know if i were to engage in this myself
it certainly would be truthful
he also talks about going to the public
shows
he says it's not necessary to go there
but if a suitable occasion ever arises
show that your principal concern is for
none other than yourself which means
wish only for that to happen which does
happen and for him only to win who does
win for you will suffer no hindrance
what is he talking about there so the
public shows would be things in which
contests were going on and people would
get very worked up about that we could
think about our sporting contest you
know with soccer football baseball all
these sorts of things basketball you
know people will place bets people will
get very invested in this team winning
or that team losing um
people can get quite
uh
worked up about this and what's going on
there is they're placing their desire
and their aversion in something that is
totally out of their control
and not even really within the control
of that that one particular team because
they're playing against another team and
then we factor in all the other things
the weather can change you know in the
chariot races and uh an axle can pop off
you know all these other sorts of things
so epictetus says refrain utterly from
shouting or laughter at anyone or great
excitement and then after you've left
do not talk a great deal about what is
to what it what took place
except in so far as it contributes to
your own improvement for such behavior
indicates that the spectacle has aroused
your admiration don't you know if you're
going to be a stoic then then be a stoic
and don't talk a lot about the
spectacle that you went to focus on you
know improving your internal life
he also says don't go rashly or readily
to people's public readings but when you
go maintain your own dignity and gravity
and at the same time be careful not to
make yourself disagreeable what are
public readings we still do this with
poetry i i don't know that that many
people go to poetry readings
but they probably should follow this
advice about don't make yourself
disagreeable because there's really only
one thing that a poet hates more than
anything else and that's another poet
right
and we could you know that's not to say
they all hate each other but there's a
lot of jealousy a lot of enviousness
within the writing community uh when you
when you go around perhaps because
there's only so much attention to to
distribute but
what public readings were
were occasions where not just poets but
historians and essayists and other
writers would you know have their
scrolls and they would read their their
writing in public
and it was kind of a public
uh occasion it was it was an event it
was something to go to to be seen at
right sort of like we
we do all sorts of gatherings like that
we have lectures and did you go to the
lecture or not um these are you know
the ancient equivalent of that so if
you're going to go
um you know behave in a seemly manner
like it says maintain your own dignity
and don't be disagreeable
here's another bit of useful advice he
says when you're about to meet somebody
especially if it's somebody who you hold
in high esteem propose to yourself this
question and what he's doing there is
he's setting up a model he's saying what
would socrates the philosopher very
important philosopher for stoicism or
zeno the founder of stoicism
have done under these circumstances and
then this will help you figure out how
to behave in those circumstances and
what benefit you can get out of engaging
that person
so he says when you go to see one of
those men who have great power propose
to yourself these thoughts prepare ahead
of time to be
disappointed
to um encounter difficulties he says
keep in mind you might not find him at
home
whoever's there might be a gatekeeper
you know if you're going to go to a
corporation uh perhaps the secretary
doesn't let you in to see the the boss
right uh there could be all sorts of
other issues that arise he says perhaps
the door will be slammed in your face
perhaps you get through and this person
pays no attention to you why because
they've got a million different things
going on themselves and they don't have
the attention to provide you right these
are all live possibilities
it says if despite all this it is your
duty to go okay go and do that
and take what comes and don't say to
yourself it was not worth the trouble
and he says this is characteristic of
the layperson that is a person who is
vexed at externals now why
was it worth the trouble
well if everything went the way it was
supposed to you got in you got listened
to maybe you came to some sort of
agreement and now you got a booking or
something's going to happen that's
wonderful
if other things came up and things
didn't go your way well you had an
occasion to actually practice stoicism
you the the layperson says
i had an occasion to get ticked off and
you know waste my time and i shouldn't
have you know got on the subway or
driven out there and oh this is stupid
right but you can say
well i have the opportunity to take my
principles and to put them into practice
and now i've i've moved myself a little
bit further along the road to fully
controlling the things that are in my
control and letting the things that are
outside of my control go
he also says something else that's very
interesting this is great advice even
for non-stoics
in your conversation
avoid making mention at great length and
excessively of your own deeds or dangers
why
it's not as pleasant for others to hear
about your adventures as it is for you
to call to mind your own dangers nobody
likes to hear
about other people
more than they like to hear about
themselves except for people who are you
know really well put together and can
listen to other people that's not the
way most people are
odds are for any one of us we have some
tendencies towards thinking more about
ourselves than others so this is very
easy for us to relate to
if you realize that you don't like
listening to other people's stories
don't impose your own stories on them or
if you're going to do so give them the
paired down thumbnail version with the
important stuff up front so they don't
have to wait for it at the very end
right
he talks about the laughter thing which
we we've already gone into then he talks
about um lapsing into foul language uh
as as similar so he says when something
like this occurs
if the occasion be suitable now notice
he's not saying whenever this occurs
just if the occasion be suitable what
does it mean for the occasion to be
suitable the other person might actually
listen to you there's a good probability
that they care about what you think and
that you might be able to have some sort
of useful effect then he says go so far
as to reprove the person that means to
to criticize them and say hey knock it
off don't talk like that i don't want to
hear that follow language but he says if
the occasion doesn't arise
and all events
show by keeping silence and blushing and
frowning that you're displeased by what
has been said now that was an ancient
way i i don't know that it's so useful
today it strikes me as being a little
passive aggressive in our contemporary
culture but back at that time that was
actually a way to show some degree of
respect to the other person by not
coming out and saying something directly
there are cultures that are that are
like that but the point is you you don't
have to say something to the other
person all the time and if we're going
to wrap all of these sayings up in in
one you know sort of pithy formulation
at the end it's do the things that
stoicism shows you you ought to be doing
and don't worry about whether other
people are doing them
[Music]
you